Speaker 1: This is so funny how the tables
have turned.
Remember when Chick fil A, the chicken fast
food restaurant was the darling of the right
wing because it took an anti-gay stance and
donations to anti LGBT organizations and conservatives
were flocking to the drive thrus and standing
in line outside Chick fil A because Chick
fil A supports traditional marriage and so-called
Christian values.
And the left was boycotting Chick fil A because
of bigotry and discrimination.
Times have changed, and I guess Chick fil
A has also changed.
Chick fil A has now come under fire from its
former right wing fans because Chick fil A
now has a statement on its website about DIY,
as they like to call it.
DIY stands for diversity, Equity and Inclusion.
And right wingers are now saying Chick fil
A has succumbed to the woke agenda.
There's a piece in Newsweek.
Chick fil A faces a Conservative Revolt for
its DIY initiative.
The company website now said This is like
speaking of toast.
This is milquetoast.
One of our core values at Chick fil A is we're
better together when we combine our unique
backgrounds and experiences with a culture
of belonging.
We can discover new ways to strengthen the
quality of care we deliver to customers, to
the communities we serve, and to the world.
We understand that getting better at together
means we learn better, care better, grow better
and serve better.
Okay, So listen, there's a couple of different
things here.
The irony is as delicious as a spicy chicken
sandwich with extra pickles and grilled jalapenos,
the same people who accused liberals of being
intolerant.
Cancel culture.
Supporting lunatics are now themselves calling
for a boycott of Chick fil A because Chick
fil A is now being inclusive and respectful.
The same people who previously defended Chick
fil A's right to express its religious beliefs,
which happen to be Christian.
Those people are now outraged that Chick fil
A is trying to live up to its mission of glorifying
God by being a good steward, by having this
D.I.Y.
inclusivity statement.
And it seems to me that some of these conservatives
must think that to be faithful to God, you
shouldn't be inclusive and want equity and
want diversity.
Seems to me that that is quite godly, isn't
it?
They think, Oh, Chick fil A wants to have
a positive influence.
I guess that means we need to boycott them
now.
Chick fil A is not perfect.
I have not done a U-turn on Chick fil A. I've
still never been to a Chick fil A. Chick fil
A is a big corporation that is calculating
what is best for them right now.
They have done some to try to repair the damage
they did in terms of their relationship with
the LGBT community based on what happened
a couple of years ago.
They have a statement.
Let's see if they prove that it's not just
lip service.
Let's see if they actually are committed to
some kind of change as a result of this.
But it is also not the enemy of the right
wing.
This is a business adapting to changing times,
trying to meet the needs and expectations
of its customers, its employees and its would
be customers.
I was thinking of trying Chick-Fil-A this
weekend with all of this hubbub.
I've never been.
I'm going to be out on Long Island for a conference
this weekend and I thought there's a bunch
of Chick fil A's there.
But then I looked at the menu.
It's pretty nuts.
Like, I don't want to you know, I'm all for
I'll try all sorts of different things.
But I looked at the menu and, you know, the
rib meat with water injected into it and formed
into a patty and then breaded and deep fried.
Like, I just don't know that I want that,
you know.
So it's it's pretty bonkers stuff.
But, you know, maybe I'll show up and get
like a grilled chicken and report back how
it is.
In the meantime, Marjorie Taylor GREENE and
her boyfriend on their latest podcast commented
about Chick fil A, and they wrongly claimed
that the left was boycotting Chick fil A because
Chick fil A would close on Sunday, which is,
of course, very much not true.
Speaker 2: So I don't see the left having
any buying power at all in the marketplace.
Speaker 3: I think that's a great analogy.
You brought up Chick fil A.
A lot of us have forgotten about Chick fil
A being being boycotted and targeted so heavily
like they did on the left.
People were mad at them simply because they
they closed their doors on Sundays because
the owners of Chick fil A or Christians and
they believe in taking a day of rest that
talks about like God says, you should rest
one day a week.
And that's what the owners of Chick fil A
decided.
That's the way they're going to run their
company and they don't apologize for it.
And the left targeted them because they're
Christian.
Speaker 1: And yeah, and.
Speaker 2: Their stance on marriage.
Speaker 1: There.
Speaker 2: Are.
Speaker 1: So even Marjorie Taylor GREENE
boyfriend having to say well it did have some
their stance on marriage.
It did also actually have to do with their
support of anti LGBT causes.
It wasn't just being closed on Sunday.
Many businesses are closed on Sunday.
Many Jewish delis are closed during Shabbat.
The net that's being closed on certain days
for religious observance is very different
than donating to anti-gay causes.
So maybe I'll go to Chick-Fil-A this weekend.
I guess I'll go grilled rather than fried
that damn the rib meat with the water injected
into it.
I'm just not big on that.
I have to admit.
It's just it doesn't sound great to me, but
I will report back if I end up at a Chick
fil A